depuis la semaine dernière la star du
foot Cristiano Ronaldo rejoint le club
dalle Nasser en Arabie donc c'est le
président du PSG jusqu'en 2025 les
chiffres de son nouveau contrat donnent
le tournis c'est 200 millions d'euros de
salaires par an voilà ça fait
555000 € par jour voilà ça vous donne
une idée par semaine par jour parce que
la Juventus était par semaine
qu'il ait une prime de 200 millions
d'euros qui puisse se rajouter pour que
Ronaldo fasse la promotion de la
candidature de l'Arabie saoudite à la
Coupe du Monde 2030 et il a présenté
donc hier après-midi au King South
University Stadium sous levation du
public il a présenté ça et vous allez
voir c'est assez incroyable parce que en
fait ils ont pas créé un appartement une
maison ils ont créé une mini-ville pour
lui il y a un supermarché c'est comme si
vous étiez dans une ville à Nancy mais
c'est que pour vous regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais ma femme ma famille et moi on
aimerait tous vous remercier pour votre
soutien pour votre accueil
et on donnera le meilleur de nous-même
merci merci à tous
ça fait un scandale incroyable je
rajoute en plus que sa femme a fait une
série sur Netflix où elle est toute en
sein dehors est-ce que maintenant en
Arabie Saoudite elle pourra se balader
avec ses saveurs parce qu'elle est riche
Cristiano donc a été vivement critiqué
pour ce choix de carrière à inattendu
alors il a donné quelques explications
celle-là c'est la meilleure je suis très
fier de cette décision à Nasser m'a
donné l'opportunité de venir pas
seulement jouer au football mais
inspirer les jeunes générations de
filles et garçons dans un pays où bien
sûr je rappelle que c'est 7 ans de
prison quand vous êtes gay c'est une
belle inspiration mais j'en ai assez dit
je crois qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
vous de ça choqué pas choqué alors pas
choqué Florian papa choqué du tout parce
que il fallait s'en émouvoir avant
Cristiano Ronaldo c'est une cash machine
depuis près de 20 ans c'est peut-être le
footballeur le plus riche de la planète
et il aura a priori pas d'équivalent et
il rejoint un pays qui projette de
candidater pour la Coupe du monde dans
une dizaine d'années conjointement avec
l'Egypte et la Grèce c'est pour ce
projet là qu'il a rejoint
mais il a pas de valeur regarde son
compte Instagram non mais regarde les
publicités dans lesquelles ils tournent
etc c'est absolument pas un modèle
d'ailleurs il est pas particulièrement
idolâtré par par la jeunesse c'est plus
Messi Mbappé qui sont dans les dans les
petits papiers des jeunes aujourd'hui
Cristiano Ronaldo tout le monde a envie
d'être aussi fort que lui mais ce qu'on
a envie de lui ressemblerait juste pour
vous dire un peu parce que moi j'ai rien
contre le foot c'est un sport populaire
j'en ai contre ce que deviennent les
joueurs de foot et ils sont souvent à
dire ça il a dit c'est un contrat unique
car je suis un joueur unique pardon en
attendant on entend pas ça en Formule 1
on entend pas ça dans le rugby ça ça
fait des mois Benoît simplement moi pour
être contre toi Cristiano Ronaldo était
élu le sportif au monde le plus généreux
du monde pour les enfants et pour les
hôpitaux faut voir tout ce qu'il a donné
ça
choqué moi je pense que s'il peut mettre
en lumière
dans son dans ce pays justement où le
droit de l'homme est très compliqué
peut-être que tout le monde va avoir une
vision différente et on va pouvoir
peut-être avancer justement parce que là
pour l'instant il y en a plein
et en plus pardonne-moi sur le plan
écologique tout ça c'est absolument mais
il y a plein il y a plein de jeunes qui
savent pas que dans ce pays
l'homosexualité et bannie que tout ça
est justement c'est pas le débat
il va peut-être pas le dire mais en tout
cas en mettant la lumière dessus on fait
des recherches et on le voit et on le
sait alors
en fait maman parce que j'entends un peu
les deux on découvre ce qui se passe
vraiment dans ce pays et en même temps
tu as raison c'est enfin Maxime et il a
obtenu une dérogation spéciale pour
vivre avec sa compagne parce qu'ils ne
sont pas mariés il faut qu'on se marie
pour habiter en Arabie Saoudite c'est la
preuve qui a un assouplissement et que
dès lors qu'il y a de l'argent derrière
on peut tout acheter enfin vous donner
une idée par exemple quand quelqu'un
Express a eu lieu l'année dernière il se
terminait j'en invite que j'embrasse ça
se terminait au Qatar et ils ont dû
négocier systématiquement parce que vous
savez qu'ils font leur il y a le trek et
puis il faut dormir c'est l'habitant il
était là le problème et ils ont dû
négocier avec le Qatar j'espère que même
s'ils apparaît faut pas que je perde
tout mes droits de moi aujourd'hui
négocier qu'à chaque fois que ça
frappait c'était un homme qui ouvrait la
porte et on parlait à un homme et jamais
à une femme c'est je juge pas c'est pour
vous donner un tout petit peu l'idée de
ce qui se passe là on parle de on était
sur le Canada
en Angleterre
parce que 200 bars par an je vois pas
une personne ici qui est pas choqué donc
je vais dire choqué et puis je vais dire
pas choqué parce qu'à un moment donné on
sait que dans le football ça génère
beaucoup d'argent et en France il y a
des footballeurs qui aiment beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent alors on est choqué en
partant de combien on est choqué à 3
millions d'euros par mois à 5 à 10 c'est
pas l'argent pour faire alors qu'est-ce
qui te choque
parce qu'il fait sur les réseaux
s'accompagne mais non c'est pas l'argent
qui soit qui serait parti en Angleterre
de demander une maison avec 17 chambres
et Michel
vous êtes rigolo mais vous demandez à
Zizou quand il était dans le sa gloire
s'il avait pas des maisons de se
confirmeuses
[Applaudissements]
un footballeur aujourd'hui qui a pas une
baraque à 15 ans on peut parler un mot
de seconde tous les deux tous les deux
et les téléspectateurs il y a 10 ans
j'étais comme tout le monde honnêtement
l'écologie j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
aujourd'hui c'est plus un sujet
aujourd'hui l'écologie c'est quelque
chose c'est bien un sujet c'est une
réalité donc tu peux continuer d'avoir
une vie mais demander une ville entière
dans un pays où il fait 1000 degrés ce
qui a demandé une ville entière d'abord
on l'a rendu une ville entière pardon
c'est un quartier où il est moins
supermarché à cause des oreilles alors
Jean-Mi moi je reste très prosaïque
franchement c'est une hypocrisie totale
bien sûr tout le monde accepterait un
pont d'or à moi mais bien sûr que si
très bien qui refuserait de gagner 200
millions par an quand tu es en fin de
carrière il lui reste un an ou deux de
jouer au foot etc voilà la retraite du
footballeur est prête en septembre à 40
ans là on va nous on va travailler
jusqu'à 64 65 e et à 30 ans 35 38 ans ça
s'arrête et moi j'aurais accepté oui
évidemment et puis on tire fuser comme
ça
à un moment donné il y a l'argent et il
y a dormir la nuit c'est deux sujets
différents
il en est pas là le type je veux dire un
moment donné c'est un génie du foot il y
a déjà une bulle ça vous fait marrer les
deux jours
Stéphanie continue non mais je pense que
le problème c'est effectivement cette
bulle spéculative du football et là on
arrive à des sommets le mec c'est le
génie du foot donc on lui propose le
type qu'il fait venir en Arabie Saoudite
lui dit voilà tu vas habiter dans un
moule il va te dire bah non je vais
prendre une petite bicoque avec des
panneaux solaires pas chauffer etc enfin
à un moment donné
il va rapporter énormément la semaine
prochaine il joue contre le PSG il faut
un match exhibition il y a 68 places
elles se sont rendus en 2 minutes les
places il y a 60000 €. il donne
énormément il fait forcément mon
caritatif il a vendu son ballon d'or il
y a quelques années voilà à peu près
100000 euros
non mais qui m'a donné
un truc à 20 € par rapport à nos
salaires j'ai vendu un porte-clé pour
les Asos pas obligé de le faire il l'a
fait pour une association pour les
enfants malades et cetera donc c'est
quelqu'un qui donne énormément de sa
personne en même temps donc je vois pas
ce qu'on lui reproche finalement il y a
cette bulle spéculative dans le foot
je vais vous demander s'il vous plaît
mais c'est juste pour faire rire son jet
donc 60 millions de livres stering
c'est un avion de chasse
19 places assises il a rien à voir 2019
18 salle de bain VIP
et la question qu'on s'est posée c'est
vrai parce qu'on va revoir sa femme
voilà sa femme a fait une série sur
Netflix la cartonné et pardon sa femme
on n'est pas dans le chèque ultime
et il y a une saison 2 qui arrive c'est
un peu c'est les Kardashian j'ai un peu
j'ai un sein à l'air et tout quand ils
seront là-bas la borne n'est pas obligé
pendant l'Arabie Saoudite elle va faire
comment ils ont le droit et c'est la
raison pour laquelle c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai mis choqué c'est
qu'en fait on est en train de voir que
dès qu'on a de l'argent bah il y a plus
de valeur il y a plus de machin il y a
plus de principe
c'est un pays hyper méga conservateur ou
les femmes n'ont pas le droit d'être
la consommation d'alcool est interdite
etc mais quand c'est Ronaldo qu'il est
extrêmement riche et qui machin bon bah
là alors vous savez quoi avec juste un
truc pour que vous sachiez de courant
parle il y a l'Arabie Saoudite et il y a
la série Netflix regardez juste la bande
originale après on change de sujet vous
verrez si c'est compatible
[Musique]
il y a 5 ans ma vie a changé
je suis la femme de l'homme le plus
suivi du monde
Cristiano est un homme merveilleux il
est tout ce qu'il y a de plus normal je
rêvais d'avoir un prince charmant à mes
côtés et aujourd'hui je l'ai
la femme de ma vie je suis fou amoureux
d'elle grâce à l'amour je vis désormais
une vie de rêve
[Applaudissements]